LinkedIn as you know is the largest
online professional platform in the
world thank you very much it has more
than 630 million members using its
network to search for it new jobs it is
20 million job postings and gets 100
million applications every single month
that's a lot of applications LinkedIn
CEO his name is Jeff Weiner he's just
ranked one of the country's top 10 CEOs
on Glassdoor top 10 the site where
employees rate their companies and
management Jeff Weiner good morning see
I want to make sure we include that
because generally no no you don't have
to say that I think it really sets a
tone about who you are and how you do
what you do so congratulations there's
not the first time you made that list
either by the way but what is the most
the most effective lesson that you've
learned about leadership yourself I
think when it comes to the leadership
one of the most important lessons I've
learned is the importance of inspiration
yeah the ability to inspire others to
achieve shared objectives to me is at
the heart of leadership mode how do you
do that I think there's three things
first is the clarity of your vision and
understand what it is you ultimately
want to accomplish the second is the
courage of your conviction because of
its truly visionary what you want to
accomplish there's gonna be a lot of
naysayers and you have to really believe
in what it is that you're trying to do
otherwise people aren't gonna follow you
and the third is something that three of
you would be quite familiar with and
that's the ability to effectively
communicate both your vision and the
courage of your kit up early every day
this is a thing that always strikes me
about Jeff I hear very few CEOs talk
about compassion that is a really key
word to you it's how you live your life
and what you believe and now you have
the compassion project yeah which means
what
well taking a step back exactly your
point about the importance of compassion
in leadership in management it's it's
really become like a first principle not
only for myself but a lot of us at
LinkedIn and with regard to compassion
more broadly defined very near and dear
to my heart just started a nonprofit
called the compassion project along with
an educational technology company called
everFi that helped design the curriculum
and the mission statement for the
nonprofit is to ensure that compassion
is taught in every elementary school
United States
to ensure that all elementary school
students understand the meaning of
compassion and can practice it yeah what
do you teach them what do you want to
know
well for starters what compassion is all
about which is putting yourself in the
shoes of another person
seeing the world through their lens for
the sake of helping them and alleviating
their suffering and at the elementary
school level that's all about seeing the
world around you seen the people around
you caring about them and acting upon it
at the grown-up level we're actually
giving out an award for compassion right
yeah you've got some finalists what's
the most innovative idea you've come
across for spreading compassion yeah so
the compassion award is actually an
inaugural award for us at LinkedIn we're
gonna be announcing the winner one grand
finalist and three runner-up the the
grand finalist will win $100,000 to help
accelerate their initiatives efforts to
bring more compassion to the world the
four semi-finalists really interesting
cool ideas one about helping refugee
families get back on their feet
another is providing counseling and
coaching to the homeless another is
providing role models for young men of
color and a fourth is a documentarian
who wants to provide filmmaking
capabilities to nonprofits and folks
without means to help tell their stories
when I see a question about I want to
squish about yeah I've got it I've got a
90 year 23 year old daughter who's
spending a lot of time on LinkedIn right
now and what is her name ya know she'll
kill me if I do what is your what is
your the money question here is what's
your one great tip for getting in a job
interview for getting well especially
with regard to LinkedIn it's leveraging
your network it's making sure that
you're able to utilize folks who can
help open doors for you people that have
a referral inside an organization that
can it's a place they want to get a job
leveraging a referral like that makes
you ten times more likely to get the
role and I have to say on the opposite
end it's really important that all of us
are conscious of that dynamic because as
exciting as that is for people like your
daughter there may be other folks who
did not necessarily go to the right
school they haven't had the right jobs
they don't have the right relationships
and we call that the network
yeah there's a virtuous cycle for people
who have the relationship there's a
vicious cycle for people who have the
skills they have the aptitude you know
but they don't have the relationships
and one of the things we've encouraged
our employees to do is take what we call
the +1 pledge to open up their networks
the people that they don't know who are
in underrepresented groups to help
create opportunities and turn vicious
cycles into virtue is Jeff Weiner thank
you very much